welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my breakdown of the Joker
movie ending hopefully you've had a
chance to see the movie we're doing a
giveaway for tickets all you have to do
to enter is just be a subscriber and
leave your favorite Joker moment on the
video please do use spoiler tags at
least till we get through the weekend
just to give everyone a chance to see
the movie and if you have not seen it
just blanket spoiler warning because we
will be talking about everything that
happens at the end of the movie most of
the questions that I've seen you guys
commenting on my Joker movie review
video it's just a question of what is
real and what is fake because the Joker
is an unreliable narrator as is his
mother or at least were led to believe that
she's an unreliable narrator because
there are a lot of questions about that
picture that she carried around of her
signed by Thomas Wayne with a special
message so as seen some fantastic
theories that you guys have had about
this but really when we talk about the
ending that starts when he learns that
he's secretly been adopted while he's at
Arkham Asylum getting his files on his
mother she had previously worked for the
Wayne's about 30 years ago and believed
that she had a relationship with Thomas
Wayne at least that's what she thinks
she keeps writing him letters eventually
Arthur reads one of the letters and in
it she tells Thomas Wayne that Arthur is
his son
so Arthur believes that he's the son of
Thomas Wayne but because a lot of the
events in Arthur's life he made up and
then you later learned things did not
happen the way that he thought that they
happened you're led to believe that that
might be fake he's not really the son of
Thomas Wayne and his mother was lying
the whole time because as Thomas Wayne
says she was institutionalized there are
even adoption papers for Arthur inside
her file we learned that the affliction
that causes him to laugh the reason
behind his crazy laugh is because of the
head trauma he received when he was
as a child
so his world starts to unravel he goes
suffocates his mother then
begins to just completely fly off the
chain starts painting himself up in
Joker makeup his former friend seemingly
that sold him the gun earlier in the
film and then ratted him out comes to
visit him because of the police to make
sure that he doesn't tell them the wrong
thing that will get him in trouble he
winds up him before he goes on
Murray Franklin's TV show in full Joker
makeup lets his smaller friend go you
were the only one that was nice to me so
at this point you're starting to
question what's real and what's fake
because he climbs into a roof
and a lot of people think that he
actually died in the refrigerator and
the rest of the movie is imagined but
the reason why I don't think that's the
case is because too much of the movie
happens in that last 15 minutes for him
to have all experienced it within his
mind while he was inside a
refrigerator so I think the takeaway
from the refrigerator is that it's him
just slowly transforming metaphorically
into the Joker character like he goes
into a chrysalis inside the refrigerator
then he merges more the Joker than he's
ever been before the basketball game
music swells up as he rolls out of his
apartment in full Joker costume and
makeup dancing down the stairs and the
montage that they put in all the
trailers but the cops that have been
after him the whole movie chase him into
the subway he uses the clown rise up
move it to stop them inadvertently
starts a riot in the subway later claims
that he has nothing to do with that
movement and Thomas Wayne himself is
also partially responsible for all these
people wearing clown masks that I'll
explain in a second you get the scene of
him waiting in the greenroom on the
Murray Franklin show that we've seen in
all the trailers where he talks to
Maria's assistant producer played by
Marc Maron one thing when you introduce
me can you introduce me as Joker sure
thing bud sounds great him being on the
TV show is meant to be a mirror of the
dream sequence from earlier in the film
it's exactly how I imagined it he says
so he dances on is this wonderful
introduction he's charming everyone he
kisses the old lady doctor then sits
down and gives his big speech about how
society is just as bad as villains how
the rich doesn't care about the poor
there's this big class war going on
during the movie no one cares about him
because rich man Thomas Wayne isn't
talking about him on live TV
the way he was talking about the three
that he earlier on the
subway he freely admits to them
and it's almost like he's taking this
weight off of his shoulders like I'm
tired of pretending that it's not funny
it's funny comedy is subjective he
claims that he didn't them to start
a movement he's not political I'm not
trying to start any kind of thing I
them because they were terrible
then he calls out Murray Franklin for
being just as terrible and he has his
iconic line what do you get when you
cross a mentally deranged loner with a
society that treats him like crap you
get what you freaking deserve then
Robert De Niro's character Murray
Franklin on live TV
remember this is taking place in the
late 70s early 80s so there was no time
to
they built into the broadcast system
everybody that was watching Marie
Franklin saw that happen the clown
movement that's happening in the streets
during the last 15 minutes of the movie
just boils over everyone just riding
everywhere in the streets their fires
cars turned over the Joker throws all
this gasoline on that fire with his
presentation he looks into the camera
and starts speaking just as the station
cuts him off then things get really
subjective this is where you're really
getting inside his head as he's being
driven away in the back of a cop car
you're meant to believe that he was
arrested by the police and he maybe gave
himself up
he's smiling as they're driving through
all the riots but then a couple of his
admirers wearing clown masks crash an
ambulance into the cop car that has him
freeing him then he wakes up on the hood
of the cop car starts dancing basking in
the adulation of all these rioting
people wearing clown masks and draws the
iconic Joker smile on his face with his
own all this happening while
Martha and Thomas Wayne are walking out
of the Excalibur theater getting their
Batman origin story where they're
down by one of Joker's admirers wearing
a clown mask
we'll call him Joe Chill for the
purposes of this video just for
continuities sake
he says you get what you deserve guns
them down and Bruce Wayne is standing
there over their dead bodies very iconic
Batman moment a lot of people wondered
if this was gonna happen because we saw
this shot in one of the trailers this is
where it starts to throw you for a bit
of a loop when it comes to false
narration what's real what's fake
because the camera cuts to him inside
Arkham Asylum in this white cell being
interviewed by a psychiatrist he starts
laughing and when the woman asks him
what the joke is he calmly replies you
wouldn't get it as the camera cuts back
to Bruce Wayne standing near his parents
dead bodies in the alleyway he starts
singing a song and then the camera cuts
again to him walking down the hallway
leaving footprints of behind him
on the white floor dancing his way out
so because they're always revealing
things that weren't happening the way
they seemed that they were happening a
lot of this is happening in Joker's mind
you're meant to wonder what's real in
this final scene and what's fake here's
what was real and here's what's fake
remember the Joker is always imagining
things in his head like he imagines
himself on Murray Franklin show when
he's watching it at the beginning of the
film I think everything is real he
really did Murray Franklin on live
TV he did surrender to the police but
then they took him straight to Arkham in
the scene of him dancing on the cop
hood is probably him just imagining that
him inside the Arkham cell that's real
but when he's walking away leaving the
footprints of blood that's meant to
imply that he that woman the
psychiatrist he was talking to and in
the process of escaping Arkham Asylum
this kind of explains why there's such a
quick seeming time jump from him dancing
on the cop car hood to appearing in the
Arkham cell is that the dancing did not
happen that's all in his head
but I do think that Joe Chill
Thomas and Martha Wayne giving Batman
his origin story that was real so I know
there's gonna be a ton of theories after
this weekend about them doing a new
Batman film with Joaquin Phoenix's Joker
something completely different
outside the DC Universe the reason why
I'm not so sure that that's gonna happen
is because of the new Matt Reeves Batman
trilogy Warner Brothers probably isn't
gonna greenlight a couple different
versions of live-action Batman at the
same time based on the age of young
Bruce Wayne here you could say that this
is close to being Ben Affleck's Batman
because Ben Affleck is playing a late
40-something Batman
during his Batman movies but a lot of
people have wondered what the joke he
was referring to was when he tells the
psychiatrist you wouldn't understand the
joke I think that was a reference to him
finally being lauded as a hero at least
in his mind despite all the terrible
things that he did the past few weeks
like I'm the hero and Thomas Wayne is
the villain the added level of irony the
Thomas Wayne was partially responsible
for his own death because he called all
these deranged people clowns that's why
they were wearing clown masks to begin
with then the meta aspect of both the
Joker in Thomas Wayne inevitably
creating their own worst villain so for
Thomas Wayne he was creating that Joe
Chill person wearing the clown mask that
wound up killing him but the more meta
aspect is as the Joker was inadvertently
indirectly creating the Batman by doing
all this - so that's why he's saying
that the psychiatrist would not
understand it because it's such a
complex but beautiful meta joke Joaquin
Phoenix was actually asked in an
interview recently what his character
would do if he were suddenly confronted
with someone dressed up like a bat
flying around Gotham fighting crime and
his answer was is that his character the
Joker would be incredibly happy at the
site he would laugh genuinely ironically
happy but delighted by how his
nihilistic view of the world was
seemingly confirmed by this crazy person
dressing up like a bat or someone that
he thought was just as crazy as him that
gets into more
joke Easter eggs you're one bad day away
from being me the Joker trying to tell
Batman that they're the exact same
person a lot of you are also asking
about the picture of Joker's mother
signed by Thomas Wayne with a really
intimate message on it making it seem
like maybe she was telling the truth
about her relationship with Thomas Wayne
is if maybe there's a small chance that
Arthur could be Thomas Wayne's son but I
think that's mostly just to throw you
for a bit of a loop I do think that she
had mental problems I do think that she
imagined her relationship with Thomas
Wayne and even if he was maybe kind of
amorous with her they probably never had
a child together Arthur really is
adopted because can you imagine what
comic book fandom would do if they tried
to say that the Joker was Thomas Wayne's
son the only version of the Joker that
his Thomas Wayne's son is the Batman who
laughs and they have not done him in the
movies yet so just remember that parts
of those final 15 minutes of the movie
the ending are fake and imagined in his
head some of them are real if there's
any other big questions that you have
about the ending of the movie though
just let me know in the comments below
but this does give you a point of origin
for this version of Batman whatever you
want him to look like Todd Phillips made
it seem like they're not planning on
doing any sequels but Joaquin Phoenix
might be lured back if the film makes
enough money they might find a way to
get him back in a couple years but I
think it's more likely that they would
just do other DC Black Label films with
other Batman villains like a really
hardcore r-rated film about the Riddler
that would be amazing but the Riddler is
going to be a character during Matt
Reeves Batman films so if you have any
other big questions about plot points in
the movie or the ending just let me know
in the comments and I'll try to address
that in my other Easter egg videos this
weekend congratulations carbo you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everybody click here for my Joker movie
review and click here for that brand new
flash season 6 crisis on Infinite Earths
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody put on a happy face I'll see
you guys tonight